Muy bien, ahora vamos a jugar lo que creo que es
un juego bastante divertido, y vamos a llamar a
este juego Crear el número más grande. Entonces,
¿cómo jugamos? Bueno, te voy a dar tres dígitos y
tienes que crear el número más grande usando esos
dígitos. Así que empecemos. Digamos que tengo un
0, un 4 y un 9. Pausa este video e intenta crear
el número más grande usando solamente un 0,
un 4 y un 9, sólo esos dígitos. Muy bien, ahora
trabajemos juntos en esto. Es posible que hayas
jugado un poco con ellos probando diferentes
combinaciones, pero la forma de pensar en esto es
poner el dígito más grande en la posición de mayor
valor. Aquí tenemos tres dígitos, así que vamos a
tener tres posiciones, entonces uno, dos y tres; así que
por supuesto esta es la posición de las unidades,
esta es la posición de las decenas y esta es la
posición de las centenas. Y dijimos que queríamos
poner el dígito más grande en la posición de mayor
valor, el dígito más grande es 9 y la posición de
mayor valor es la posición de las centenas, por
lo que pondremos el 9 allí. ¿Por qué queremos
hacer eso? Bueno piénsalo, 9 centenas es mucho
más grande que tener 4 centenas o 0 centenas,
e incluso si colocaras el 9 en otro lugar, si
tuvieras 4 centenas aquí y tuvieras 9 decenas
o 9 unidades, eso no se acercaría para nada a
9 centenas, por lo que querrás poner el número
más grande en la posición de mayor valor. Luego
queremos poner el siguiente número más grande
en la siguiente posición de mayor valor, así
que a continuación está la posición de las
decenas y el siguiente número más grande
es el 4, por lo que pondremos el 4 ahí,
y luego sólo quedaría poner el 0 en la posición
de las unidades: nos quedan 940. Y si no me crees,
intenta intercambiar algunos de estos dígitos;
no obtendrás un número tan grande como 940:
si pones el 0 en el lugar de las decenas, tendrás
904, que es claramente menor que 940. Así que
juguemos otra ronda de Crear el número más grande.
Voy a darte otros tres números, digamos un 2,
un 8 y un 4. Crea el número más grande usando
estos tres dígitos. Pausa este video y trata de
resolverlo. Está bien, es la misma idea, vamos a
tener tres posiciones porque tenemos tres dígitos:
la posición de las centenas, la posición de
las decenas y la posición de las unidades;
y ahora tenemos que poner el número más
grande en la posición de mayor valor. Bueno,
el número más grande es 8, la posición de
mayor valor es la de las centenas, así que
tomaremos ese 8 para representar 8 centenas;
y luego el siguiente número más grande es 4,
la siguiente posición de mayor valor es la de
las decenas, así que pongamos 4 en las decenas,
y luego, por último pero no menos importante,
tenemos que poner el 2 en la posición de las
unidades. Entonces 842 es el número más grande
que podemos crear usando un 2, un 8 y un 4.